welcome back we continue to show you
around Southern California thanks to the
sponsors of this segment visit Anaheim
on our trip we stop by unsung Brewery
it's filled with good beer a growing
community and one-of-a-kind artifacts
check it out
well today we are saying cheers to beers
if you are visiting Anaheim you gotta
check out unsung Brewery that's where we
are right now I am here with the owner
Mike thank you so much for having us I
appreciate it thank you this place is
awesome so much to look at tell us a
little bit about the story behind it
well I always was a big fan of comic
books growing up and when I got into the
beer industry I just thought that it
would be a great meld of beer nerds and
comic nerds kind of uniting together and
that's what we're trying to create well
you definitely nailed it and let's walk
around and look a little bit I mean from
Spider-Man on the ceiling to Legos a
little bit of everything you said a lot
of these items are actually donated to
you guys yeah it's virtually almost 100
donated
um we just have this really awesome
community that really really grasped
with the whole comic theme so anything
from Star Wars to Marvel DC
um we just love it well and speaking of
community you guys host a lot of fun
events in here as well I see yoga and
beer on the wall what are some of the
fun things you guys do here yeah you
beer we do that on Sundays once a month
and we also have this really cool one
called drink and draw where artists will
come out and they'll just get a coaster
and they'll just draw something really
cool and they get a buck off their beer
it's a really good crowd how fun I'm
sure you have such a community base here
and you know it's fun to visit and check
out new places but hey we're here to
talk about beer and it's the holiday
season I hear you guys have a special
holiday beer tell us about that we do so
every year since we've been open we've
come out with Saint Nick our doodle and
it's a snickerdoodle cookie beer
inspired so it's definitely indulgent
but it's good for the holidays so well
you had me at Snickerdoodle I say we
pour it what do you think sounds good
all right and as you're pouring tell me
a little bit about some of the other
beers you have on the wall over here and
they all have kind of a fun story behind
them yeah so you know we like to have
fun with the the comic thing and so we
thought why not give most of our beers
an identity like a physical identity and
so we'll create a comic book hero from
scratch and it has something to do
typically with the beer that we're
creating like I love all of the detail
of everything in here especially on
these cans tell us what we're looking at
so these are our package products where
we've created those characters and kind
of gave some life to the beer so for
example here's lumino he's obviously a
baseball pitcher he's got a really cool
backstory
um you know another one here we finally
made a villain called chatter Spike it's
an IPA a double dry hop and like I said
the artwork kind of speaks for itself it
kind of is engaging and then on the back
of it you can read the uh the origin
story and some of the cool facts about
the beer and the character this was
awesome and so can people purchase the
cans as is when they come in or how does
that work yep yep they can purchase them
they come in four packs we're also in
local grocery stores and Total Wines and
that sort of thing too I love it Mike
this is so cool everything just has so
much character in here this artwork on
the wall tell us about that so when we
were creating the uh the mural we said
well these are going to be our core
beers that we're going to start off with
um and so we had this local artist down
in San Diego that really conceptually
would go through the process with me
um I'd say you know we're looking for
something that's more alien-esque or
something that's more like brute like
the Hulk
um and yeah we started to create our own
things and came up with our own names so
well how fun Mike thank you so much for
having us in here you guys are
celebrating six years so you're doing
something right the people love it and
we're just so excited to be out here and
try out your beers thank you so much
it's been awesome well thank you Mike
and cheers to the holidays right yes
and now is your chance to win a
two-night stay at the JW Marriott
Anaheim Resort tickets to a hockey game
at the Honda Center and a four pack of
tickets to Knott's Berry Farm you can
just go to 8newsnow.com and enter
today's keyword which is Vacation all
right A lot of people excited